Master Class sur le Cold Reading : deuxième ! (clap)
Comme vous me l'avez demandé suite à la première vidéo sur le cold reading, voici donc la suite.
Dans la première, on va dire que j'abordais un petit peu la définition
et les généralités sur comment pratiquer ou en tout cas comment s'y préparer.
Et dans les nombreux commentaires et échanges qu'on a eu ensemble
à chaque fois il y a quelque chose quand même qui revient c'est :
on en fait quoi après une fois qu'on a commencé à observer ou à déduire des choses ?
Je vais passer en revue avec vous une douzaine d'exemples et ce qu'on pourrait en retirer.
Les poignées de main. Les fameuses poignées de main qu'on connait bien,
qu'on soit un homme ou une femme, ça nous arrive de serrer la main.
La poignée de main à 2 mains.
Vous savez, celle où la personne vous prend la main et l'accompagne avec la 2ème main pour resserrer,
pas au niveau du poignet, vraiment au niveau de la main.
Donc elle enveloppe un peu notre main.
C'est un comportement tout à fait typique des personnes qui cherchent un petit peu
à cacher leurs émotions, leur initimité
ou à chercher le rapprochement un peu plus qu'ils ne devraient.
Surtout dans le cadre d'une poignée de main avec quelqu'un qu'on connait pas ou peu.
Si je devais sortir une phrase à cette personne pour valider ce comportement là avec lui,
je ne prononcerais pas ces mots là, surtout pas.
Par contre, je pourrais tout à fait lui dire :
"Parfois, vous vous sentez très seul ou un petit peu trop seul,
et je pense qu'avoir des gens autour de vous qui vous soutiennent, qui sont avec vous,
c'est quelque chose de très important pour vous."
Et là vous ferez mouche, parce que ce genre de préoccupation est tout à fait juste
pour une personne dont vous avez déduit tel comportement via la poignée de main.
Dans la même idée, quelqu'un qui fait une grosse poignée de main, ferme,
un petit peu trop ferme, un petit peu trop violente sur l'échelle de la poignée de main
lui, on pourrait facilement lui dire :
"Récemment, vous avez découvert qu'il y a des gens qui ne se comportaient pas
conformément un petit peu à vos valeurs, à vos usages,
et ça, c'est quelque chose qui vous a déçu."
Puisque cette poignée de main est typique des gens qui sont sur la défensive
ou des gens qui sont agressifs ou des gens qui sont en colère.
Donc cette lecture là est liée à l'interprétation encore une fois de cette poignée de main un petit peu trop ferme.
D'ailleurs on pourrait penser que le côté agressif et colère,
il est facile à déduire via la poignée de main très franche comme ça, trop forte
alors qu'elle fonctionne aussi avec la poignée de main trop molle, la poignée de main un peu désabusée.
C'est en général une colère un peu latente, un manque de volonté,
les gens qui ont du mal à s'engager dans les choses.
Et là, vous pourriez lui dire :
"Récemment, vous vous êtes senti un petit peu exploité.
Vous ressentez d'ailleurs souvent des émotions qui sont tout à fait contradictoires."
Mais par rapport à ce qu'on a vu ensemble dans la vidéo précédente,
vous n'en êtes pas encore à la poignée de main.
Vous observez les gens, vous les regardez marcher.
Alors on va parler un petit peu de la démarche, et oui !
Une démarche assurée et surtout des mouvements vifs,
au delà de la démarche en elle-même, la manière de prendre son téléphone,
la manière dont il va regarder quelque chose,
la manière dont la personne va sortir son ticket de métro,
c'est forcément quelqu'un de directif.
Donc on pourrait même y aller un petit peu par la flatterie :
"Vous êtes quelqu'un d'organisé, de réfléchi, vous savez vraiment analyser une situation rapidement."
Un homme, (c'est un petit peu différent pour une femme),
un homme qui fait de grandes enjambées, c'est quelqu'un qui a de l'ambition,
c'est quelqu'un qui veut y arriver, c'est quelqu'un qui a l'esprit d'initiative.
Alors forcément, si on parle à cette personne là,
on peut pas lui dire "vous êtes un petit peu trop ambitieux".
Le but du cold reading, c'est aussi de dire à la personne ce qu'elle ressent et non ce qu'elle est vraiment.
Donc on pourrait lui dire :
"Vous êtes quelqu'un de particulièrement adaptable,
vous savez quel chemin prendre et en général, vous vous faites confiance dans vos décisions.
Vous avez de bonnes qualités de perception et ça, vous le savez."
Quelqu'un qui marche avec les mains dans les poches mais avec les bras un petit peu fléchis hein,
pas complètement enfoncés parce que ça c'est peut-être simplement pour se protéger du froid,
mais quelqu'un qui, à une température normale, marche un peu comme ça les mains dans les poches.
Pas forcément nonchalant, on va dire une démarche normale mais les mains un petit peu enfoncées dans les poches.
Alors là aussi on peut se dire qu'est ce qu'on fait de cette information,
le fait que la personne elle ait une attitude de découragement.
Qu'est ce que ça veut dire en fait, plus profondément chez elle ?
Comment on pourrait faire un bon reading de ça ?
On pourrait ramener ça simplement d'un point de vue sociétal.
Vous vous sentez un petit peu exploité par les exigences du monde qui vous entoure,
par toutes les obligations et tout ce qu'on attend de vous.
L'assurance par contre de la démarche d'une femme, ça se traduit un petit peu différemment :
les épaules sont droites, son pas est un peu balancé, un petit peu détendu,
en général y a un mouvement aussi, une espèce d'oscillation au niveau des hanches
et ça s'accompagne pas forcément d'une rapidité comme chez l'homme.
Vous comprenez où je veux vous emmener pour cette deuxième étape dans le cold reading.
C'est vraiment où est ce qu'on peut aller au delà de l'information qu'on voit
et qui peut parfois paraitre évidente. Qu'est ce qu'on en fait de ça ?
Imaginons que vous vous faites passer pour un voyant, un médium,
c'est pas quelque chose que je vous recommande de faire mais c'est pour vous mettre dans la situation,
et que quelqu'un vienne vous parler et que cette personne là sent l'alcool,
En bon cold reader que vous êtes,
vous allez vous dire ok, la personne vient de boire un verre récemment.
Suivant l'heure de la journée, vous allez déterminer si c'est quelque chose de logique pour tout le monde
ou si c'est plus problématique.
Mais si on cherche à élargir et qu'on se dit, peu importe le moment de la journée,
qu'est ce qui pourrait être commun à toute personne qui sent l'alcool, qui a bu.
Et là je parle bien de l'odeur de l'alcool d'ailleurs, pas d'une marque d'alcool spécifique.
Quelqu'un qui a bu une bière il sent la bière. Quelqu'un qui a trop bu de bière va sentir l'alcool.
Il y a quand même une différence. Et bien on pourrait tout à fait lui dire :
"Je pense que vous avez une consommation d'alcool qui est plutôt raisonnable.
Néanmoins, vous avez été préoccupé par votre propre consommation.
Vous vous êtes déjà récemment posé la question si c'était exagéré ou pas.
D'autant plus que quelques personnes vous en ont déjà parlé."
C'est un parcours logique et tout à fait commun aux personnes qui boivent de l'alcool.
Donc les affirmations sont vraies pour la plupart et en tout cas, seront toujours vraies dans le temps.
Si on enlève le "récemment", on est sûr à 100%.
Et ça marche avec tous les signes, qu'ils soient physiques, qu'ils soient physiologiques.
Quelqu'un qui hausse le ton, en général, c'est pas quelqu'un forcément qui veut parler plus fort que vous.
C'est quelqu'un qui commence à avoir le doute dans la conversation
et peut-être même le doute sur le fait qu'il ait encore la main dans la conversation.
Et il veut être sûr de la reprendre, il veut être sûr d'avoir le pouvoir.
Donc on peut dire que c'est quelqu'un de perspicace,
mais on pourrait aller plus loin en disant que c'est quelqu'un qui ne laisse rien lui échapper.
Quelqu'un qui va parler un peu plus lentement ou qui va avoir des fins de phrase un petit peu trainantes,
qui a un rythme et une intonation monotone,
qui parait un peu défaitiste, un petit peu dans le découragement,
vous allez pas lui dire "vous êtes défaitiste ou dans le découragement"
et puis vous n'allez rien faire de cette information là d'une manière brute.
Par contre vous pouvez modeler cette information encore une fois.
On est sûr que cette personne là, elle désire des choses.
Donc c'est quelqu'un qui désirait ardemment quelque chose y a assez peu de temps encore
et si on lui rappelle cette information alors ça va lui en faire prendre conscience
et on peut même l'amener à prendre conscience de l'importance que ce désir avait dans sa vie
alors que là, il l'a un petit peu laissé de côté.
Quelqu'un de très bruyant, de très exubérant qui bouge beaucoup,
qui parle beaucoup et qui parle fort. Qu'est ce que c'est ?
D'après vous, je vous laisse chercher.
Et là vous dites c'est quelqu'un qui veut attirer l'attention sur lui. Oui pourquoi pas.
C'est quelqu'un qui veut prendre la place. Oui pourquoi pas.
Mais ça traduit quoi ? Au fond, au fond, au fond des choses ?
Ça traduit une frustration. C'est quelqu'un qui est plutôt frustré en réalité.
Si on voulait lui dire une vérité et faire mouche, on pourrait lui dire :
"Malgré le fait que tu essaies de faire bonne figure,
y a plein de choses que t'avais espérées et qui se sont pas réalisées.
Pour une raison ou pour une autre mais au fond de toi, tu as un peu du mal à le vivre."
Et là en réaction, vous allez avoir quelqu'un qui plie les bras,
qui baisse un petit peu la tête, qui fronce un petit peu les sourcils.
Bref, qui va vous offrir tous les signes du refus parce qu'il ne voudra pas admettre cette phrase
parce qu'elle aura trop marché.
Voilà je pense que vous avez bien saisi le message de cette deuxième vidéo sur le cold reading.
Il y en aura une troisième rassurez-vous en tout cas si vous le voulez.
Dites le moi dans les commentaires, vous pouvez m'en parler.
Et je vais laisser un petit peu de temps pour que vous puissiez mettre ces conseils là en application,
avant de vous faire passer, essayer en tout cas de vous faire passer, une 3ème étape là dedans.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Si elle vous a plu, je vous conseille un petit cold reading sur ma personne
pour peut-être la gratifier d'un petit POUCE EN L'AIR.
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
puisque que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an,
on approche de la moitié de l'année d'ailleurs et de la moitié des vidéos,
donc rendez-vous demain à 11h. Ciao !